so it's just rare that you find all in
coach and all in fighter and they get
together and you guys have such unique
working I'm why more than all in same
with you addicted you know like yeah
like if I'm not completely like
full-blown into it I mentally am [ __ ]
when I get home you know now coming off
of the second victory over Cody and then
being able to stop them even quicker
this time and in just all the crazy [ __ ]
talking that led up to that fight and
the results of the first fight I mean
that's got to be very satisfying to you
that everything is going according to
plan
absolutely man it is especially was the
whole build-up you know I was like two
years of just [ __ ] nothing to deal
with that man and that's not the kind of
person I am you know I'd be in the
mountains you'd not be able to get a
hold of me hunting or just camping like
if I if I could disappear I take the
advantage to do it you know so that
crazy attention and just like the [ __ ]
talk and the TV show them accusing me of
everything like you know that took a lot
you know and so for all that to be like
taking off my shoulders feels great for
you though there's God that's got to be
a real feeling of like retribution to
like no matter what they said yeah you
you had the right idea they might not
have been happy that you decided to do
it for yourself and the right move for
yourself was to go and go to Colorado
and be with Dwayne but obviously you
were right yeah 100% I was right I mean
that's why I made the decision I'm
definitely you know you gotta be selfish
in this this sport you got to do what's
best for yourself in some ways without
[ __ ] people over you have to be
selfish of course I mean we had to know
what's best for you and right so the
ultimate decision for me was when I got
an ultimatum you know like you Ryan knew
how much I liked training with Dwayne he
knew how great it was for my mentality
and we just vibe right away you know and
they didn't and so when he gave me the
ultimatum like look man you're either
doing your camp with Dwayne you're doing
with us so I was like well then you
don't have my best interest at heart I'm
out of here you know like I sold my
house but moving out to Colorado like I
dropped everything and went you that was
tough and I was a tough situation to go
through and yeah I made the right choice
well your your decision the way you
approached it was very similar to what
you were doing to because when I talk to
you like I'm gonna open up my own gym in
Colorado and I remember thinking
whenever it someone thinks they're gonna
start from scratch with a new gym by
themselves
ooh I mean I wish you well but damn
that's a lot of work you know as well as
anybody yes sir I've known since I was a
kid I was gonna be a world champion and
have my own Academy in Colorado check
check Wow starting a gym is tough man
we're doing it now while we've been
going through it for the last year year
and a half down here in Southern
California yeah and the new place is
called the training lab the training lab
it's building sorry I in rain yeah cuz
mark muñoz had rain mm-hmm down in Lake
Forest and Sam calivita the guy that I
moved down for for her strength
conditioning just his crazy mind he's
beyond smart like heal everything he
talks about like I have to be at his
house for hours pre-much doing a podcast
with him to figure out what he's talking
about and usually always goes over your
head you know I've gone like I said I'm
always full blown I mean 100% and so as
soon as he started showing me the
science behind what my body needs to do
if it were for my diet my recovery the
days I'm working out my the way I'm
doing my string conditioning what if I'm
gonna go bigger or how far I am from
camp like everything has a rhyme and
reason like every calorie ie every
macronutrient I eat he's got it down
written down he's like this guy stays up
late and works and he doesn't do it for
the money or the pride like he doesn't
want anything like we do it out of his
garage you know it's like an old Rocky
style training with Drago science